this morning in our birth matter series
a devastating and mysterious underwater
disease is sweeping down the coast of
Florida scientists don't know exactly
what this disease is but it is already
infected about half of the coral species
in the region our Mark Phillips recently
flew to the remote Dry Tortugas National
Park in the Gulf of Mexico to join a
team of scientists racing against time
to save the coral mark good morning good
morning from the Dry Tortugas about 70
miles west of Key West Florida there are
plenty of good reasons for diving off of
Florida's coast but these divers aren't
here to just have fun on the coral reefs
that here to try to save them
something is killing the coral that
grows along Florida's coast and these
divers are part of a last-ditch effort
to try to save it so this disease event
is unprecedented unprecedented says
national parks fisheries biologist Megan
Johnson because of the speed with which
the disease attacks and kills about half
the coral species on Florida's reefs
unprecedented because the pandemic has
lasted five years so far when most reef
infections last just a year or so and
unprecedented because marine scientists
say the coral is already threatened by
warming ocean temperatures and so is
more vulnerable to whatever this mystery
disease is what do we know about what is
it why is it doing this what we know
it's an infectious waterborne disease
and we don't know how it started or
where it originated from and we know
that it's traveling at a pretty fast
rate down the wave tract the bug or
whatever it is was first discovered off
Miami in 2014 and has been on a
relentless lethal march north and south
ever since in just five years this
disease has traveled from north of Palm
Beach 350 miles to Key West and it's
still moving but it hasn't hit the
relatively pristine waters of the Dry
Tortugas yet and so a bold rescue effort
is underway
scientists from NOAA Florida wildlife
and the University of Miami have begun
to do what is normally the worst thing
you can do on a reef they've been
chipping off healthy living coral before
the disease gets to it they've been
collecting it on a research vessel where
it's catalogue this one's three and a
half centimeters they've been storing it
in vets coral condos they call them
so that when if the disease passes the
coral can be replanted and it's hoped
the reef system can be restored maybe
these will serve as the brood population
to then make more babies once flippers
crossed once once the disease has passed
yes but you know even to do this process
we're looking at you know another two to
five years this is a long it's a long
journey a journey whose next stop is at
the University of Miami and then other
facilities across the south to wait we
just had the warmest month on record
here in Miami Florida and not just air
temperatures but water temperatures as
well and that was June 2019 so the fact
that we're breaking records in June it's
really unless and if the disease stops
killing the coral there's no point time
to replant it and nobody can say when or
even if that day might come
that's just terrible think about that
there so sure that that reef is in
trouble that they're actually taking it
apart preemptively you know to save it
unless people think that why are they
doing this the reefs sustain the ocean
they sustain life in the ocean they
sustain us yes comes out of the ocean
think about that next time you have a
fish on your plate but yeah but don't
you admire and marvel at people who take
the time to make the the earth to plant
it better for all of us that they're
doing that yeah the hope is that it
finds a way like that as mark as mark
put it flippers cross mark Phillips -
thanks